The Joe Rogan Experience without making
light or or trying to be disrespectful
like
if the things that I tried to
um figure out like a like a game like a
video game was sex money power right
like as an artist
I had subscribed to the starving artist
like type right I was like Top Ramen
you know holes in your clothes like like
homeless like I was like that is what a
real artist is until I met a successful
artist until I
I was like oh [__] like you can have a
manager and an agent in an office and
like you can like not starve and
and I remember at that point I was in my
early 20s
I was like man people sure like talk
about money a lot right like it seems to
be like this thing that causes a lot of
problems in marriages and business and I
go
it doesn't
seem that hard to me as some and I'm
saying this as a guy in my 20s that's
poor I'm like what if I just like try to
be as rich as possible for the next 10
years or five years like what if that's
my singular Focus
and so
I did it and it you know it was a lot of
work but like the video game for of
money is over for me now right like I
like at every industry gambling the
stock market
um
like even like people go oh that's like
this Korean Force Gump and he just he
was like this
um like this uh homeless guy that like
that got lucky with Facebook I'm like
that was like a lot of work to make that
happen you know
um and I was already kind of wealthy
when I when I made that deal but people
like to tell that story so I made
millions of dollars gambling I made
millions of dollars with my art I made
millions of dollars with Facebook and
it was a lot of hard work but I'm like
it's kind of if I wanted to
you tell me how cringe I was I sound and
I'll just stop but I'm like it's not
gonna be that hard for me to become a
billionaire at a certain level right
like I've amassed hundreds of millions
I'm like if that's my goal now if that's
my video game and then I know
billionaires I mean Sean Parker and Mark
being the most but I know tons of like
secret billionaires right and I go I
don't want any of their lives I don't
want I don't want any of like it's just
money you don't have to have their life
right to have money
right and you don't have to think about
money if you have it right the problem
with money is people become obsessed
with it because it's so difficult to
attain and there's so much societal
value right put on being wealthy right
that it becomes the thing instead of a
thing I mean I have I have a friend that
has like hundreds of billions of dollars
and hundreds of hundreds of billions
like one of the you know I have one too
yeah and you you know how weird those
guys are right we're guys
and and I'm pretty close with them he's
not just like a you know and I said
we're having dinner and I was like
feeling confident
I was like give me one he's like what I
was like give me one one billion and
he's like I don't understand yeah I was
like give me one billion and he's like
I was like [__] you know I don't
need it like you know I'm not gonna go
buy cars and houses he's like what do
you want what do you want to do with
that he's like
Dave I don't know if you know how money
works you don't just go up to someone
and ask them for a billion I go
[__] I just did and he's like
well do you have a plan are you going to
show me charts and graphs I was like no
it's all going to be Instinct I will
take that 1 billion and he's like dude
you got to come to me with like I'm not
saying no but you got to have a better
you know you gotta you gotta you gotta
have like how are you gonna Echo I
promise you I will spend it like like
the most irresponsible possible like
it'll be like exactly because most of
these people that have billions they're
like Geniuses and they spent everything
is down to a fraction and they they just
grind and crunch numbers in their brain
and that's not how I think I think very
abstract I think and I go I'm gonna do
stuff that on paper makes absolutely no
sense and I promise you I will change
the planet with that money like I'm
gonna do [__] that and then he was like
he was he didn't say no but he was
thinking it over and he's like dude
there's like there's no way like my
money guys are gonna do this and then I
sat there and I thought about it because
money is power I was like dude I don't
on a billion dollars I don't want that
responsibility and ultimately he was
like ah no and I was like thank you so
this is a wild thought yeah spontaneous
yeah if you had given it to me he would
have he would have [__] I would have
been like those weird people I was like
I don't want to touch that I don't want
to touch it tried it out for a while
right you would have tried it out for a
while and then you would have gone back
to being you right and then so
so that has that game of that video game
of money has no no
um it's not fun for me anymore because
I've I've so years ago like 2009 was my
last Archer where I actually sold stuff
for money and uh and I didn't feel good
it was like
the my gallery Steve lazarides is like
banksy's banksy's a guy and he's like
Joe like you're on fire Street Art's on
fire right now like what do you want to
do I go it's gonna be in La it has to be
in La it has to be on Rodeo Drive like
it has to be on the most expensive
Street in the world and I want like
every celebrity there and like you know
and so
it did it happened it was like it was a
show in Beverly Hills all the
celebrities came all the fancy people
came I sold all the art and the next day
I didn't feel any different and and then
at that point the artist gets
objectified to like just I got a
Basquiat I got a Cho I got a baby and
I'm like I'm like the guy that's buying
my art that can afford it he doesn't
care about the art he just wants to like
it's a dick contest right he just wants
to show off like hey I gotta show and
I'm like
I'm pretty sure that's not what the
universe wants for me to like just make
expensive stuff
um so at that point I told my manager
and everyone I work with I'm like
everything now is free like painting
with kids painting with guys just out of
jail painting with at-risk youth murals
music anything where it's free that's
what I'm about I'm not you know or if I
like like someone I'll just trade or
give it to them but I'm not selling [__]
anymore so that kind of like ended like
you know and then I had uh Finance guys
and everything about wealth management
is about how to preserve wealth and make
more money and I go
uh let's do like a Monte Carlo
simulation and figure out when I'm gonna
die by my lifestyle of How I Live and
let's get it down so that I have zero by
the time I'm done like I wanna and
they're like
so every business decision I've made
since I've made that decision is I just
lose money I just lose money and then
um the video game of sex which I wasn't
very good at is age 0 to 30. I'd been
with
five six maybe seven girls like and they
were all like long-term kind of
relationships there was no like
one-night stands and then
at that point like 29 30 I was like
I'm really not good at this like I don't
got any game I'm not and
um
like the same way
if you saw me in my 20s as like a street
urchin like Street kid and and he's like
I'm gonna be the richest artist in the
world you'd be like you know what the
odds of that happening are like it's
it's ridiculous in that same way and
like not to sound vulgar or you know
objectify women but that's what I did at
that age I was young and I was like
um I'm tired of the Asians or like
sexless small dick you know the the math
nerd like I want to [__] the most amount
of women as possible and that was even
more ridiculous than me saying I want to
be the richest artist and then
and then I just went on a tear for a
decade right like I just it was awkward
at first and then
um like a video game at the end a
combination of like
like a comedian working out their
material right
and with the oncoming social media and
all the you know internet stuff I could
figure out
on the dates I've been on which material
killed like what what did I say to make
what girl laugh and you know and and I
would have all those like a crazy person
like in my notes folders and I could say
the perfect combination of words to make
a girl laugh or like so using everything
at my display anything like money uh uh
you know fun a charm like jokes uh Power
like I'll get you on this thing or like
just cueing in on what is it that you
want and I can get you that and
you know I was sleeping with multiple
women a day and I was like this
like you would never believe
I okay not you I would never believe
what I was doing like I was every night
tens tens tens like Victoria's Secret
models A-list celebrities just like I
was like whoa whoa whoa and
you know I got to a point where I was
like I wasn't
my friends in a debate of they're like
you're you were like a week away from
sucking dick and I was like I was like
it's probably like more like two days
away because it just gets there right
like I was just like in rooms like
having threesomes group sex and I was
like
I'm an artist I should you know and my
parents are convinced I was like I was
in a car uh going to an art show uh with
my parents in Mexico City and my mom you
know she's like completely invested in
my career and she's like hey you know um
Andy Warhol used to do like 10 20
push-ups and then his mom would give him
like a Snicker bar and I was like that's
an interesting fact mom I didn't know
that and he was gay and I was like oh
okay cool you know Leonardo da Vinci
when he used to go out like he would no
one would know he's an artist he
wouldn't have like a speck of paint on
him and I was like oh I didn't know that
Mom and he was gay and I was like what
what where's this going and then my
dad's in the front driving he's like
he's not gay I told you he's not gay and
my mom's like you know we're Christian
and you know but we know that you're an
artist and we know you haven't brought a
woman home in like 10 years
um so just it's okay you could come out
of the closet and I was like
and I was like I I like I love being gay
so much like I I'm not like I just I
almost wish I was right like I
when I play like Dungeons and Dragons or
a role-playing game or or uh RPG like
video game or
anytime I act or do anything that's like
online or like a game I always want to
be a gay guy like I just love it I love
that feeling I want to play gay guys if
you know and but I just don't love dick
I want to I want to love it but I just
why do you want to I I just like part of
it is like I my shame makes me Shameless
and like I like it when it hurts kind of
thing like
I just
I got close where there was a
transsexual woman I think her name was
ever like her penis was right here and I
was like it's right there I should just
like at least lick it or touch it at
least just to say I tried it and I could
say I didn't like it or I did like it
but I just couldn't I was like I was so
bored not of just [__] or women or
whatever I just was bored of the
Endeavor of that and then
and then you know you meet people and
everyone has their game like Hollywood
people like I get that Emmy or that
Oscar or
you know and so
I I like picked the game I want to play
money pout and then it's like I sit here
and the thing that I learned the number
one important lesson from gambling is
get out while you're ahead is like I
love how much money I have right now
like it's the perfect amount I love
that um like I have no regrets like I've
had sex with so many different women
that like I'm just I don't need that
anymore I'm so I could be a monk for the
rest of my life if I want to you know
like and so that there's only one final
Quest and that's the spiritual Quest
right and that's where like people's
issue like the answer is love and it's
like it is right and like like
um
like there will be [__] there's [__]
that we talked about before we start
recording that we can't and then there
will be [__] that we talk about later
and and we live in this world now where
it's like it's a crazy world right and
the answer is love and everyone says it
and it's in movies and it's in books but
it's what does that path look like and
so
I go towards where I feel that and
I feel that in Africa when I go to
Africa I feel that like in my soul to my
bones and you know I look like this in
Austin no one judges me like you would
think going to Africa the places I go
where there's no Asians that they would
say [__] but they don't they just accept
me they call me brother they take me in
they show me their lives and they're
like you're just part of our tribe now
and I'm like it makes me want to cry you
know so
and the fact that you know I have this
beautiful relationship with you and you
know you let me talk about this stuff
and then those words get to
you know like I don't know Logan Paul
that guy calls me up right after the
show he's like take me to Africa bro
take me I'm like uh okay you know like
and and it's just it's just a tremendous
thing and then you know we we made this
film and it's
you know it's
it's like the best documentary I've ever
seen so if anyone like uh wants to see a
trailer or we are hodza the maleka
foundation